There's a really good article making the rounds
about supposedly independent swing vote
and the argument is from this article that
essentially they don't really exist. And this
is something I've been talking about with
you guys for years at this point. As you know,
if you've been around for a while with the
show, I have frequently questioned the reality
of a truly independent or undecided voter
this election, especially when we think how
could someone really be undecided between
Donald Trump and really just about anything
else. But even beyond this election or beyond
the world of Trump. This has been a question.
In this particular case, the contrast are
so clear between Trump and anything else that
anybody who's paying any attention and who
understands what's going on, it seems almost
inconceivable that there would really be an
independent swing voter that would rationally
and carefully decide either to vote for Donald
Trump or for somebody else. And this idea
of an independent swing voter has actually
almost turned into a meme, the meme of the
enlightened centrist because it makes such
little sense quite frankly.
And we saw some interviews on CNN a few months
ago, which I played for you with uneducated
white women. What I mean by that is is white
women without college educations, some of
whom had voted for Barack Obama and later
for Donald Trump. And it was a combination
as we saw of people who were simply uninformed
about the positions of the candidates and
were sort of stumbling around. And then also
some simple ignorance was a factor as well.
And this gets us to political scientists,
Rachel byte coffers theory, which is there
is no such thing as an actual independent
swing voter. Rachel byte coffer very accurately
predicted the results of the 2018 midterms.
And one of the things that her model does
is it doesn't care about so-called independent
swing voters. And in fact her theory about
elections lines up perfectly with something
that I've been screaming about to anybody
who will listen since the day Donald Trump
was elected.
Elections are not shaped by people who changed
their minds, but they are changed rather by
who decides to vote. I've been saying for
years now, trying to convince Trumpists to
vote for a Democrat is not a strategy and
it is a waste of time. Finding people on our
side and getting them to vote is the way to
go. There's this conventional wisdom which
is not always so wise that there's something
like a, if you have 55 turnout in the U S
which is a common turnout for elections, that
15% of that 55% that chooses to vote are so-called
swing voters and they turn the election. You
have to convince those swing voters to vote
for your candidate and this assumes way more
rationality, effort and consideration than
most voters are actually putting into voting
decisions. It's not a pejorative ad hominem,
it's just the reality. And to quote Rachel
byte coffer, she says the idea that there
is this informed and engaged American population
that is watching these political events and
watching their elected leaders and assessing
their behavior and making a judgment and it
is just not true.
And as she points out, it's not really about
candidates swinging individual voters from
one candidate to another. It's about candidates
engaging and activating certain coalitions
and groups of voters. Now, when other political
scientists are asked about Rachel's theory,
many disagree and they say, no way, there
are swing voters. There's tons of people who
voted for Obama and then ultimately for Trump
in 2016 or voted for Bernie in the primary
and then Trump or Hillary in the 2008 primary
and all these different contingencies of people
that appear to swing from one side to the
other. They exist of course anecdotally and
in small numbers, but that really what you
are talking about is not a number that swings
elections. What changes in a more significant
way is who is engaged and therefore who shows
up. It's not the same people switching between
Republican and democratic candidates.
That is moving elections. Now, if you believe
Rachel byte coffer, this suggests a totally
different election strategy and different
metrics for evaluating who can win the electability
question. When you look at a candidate, if
Rachel is correct, you think about would an
imaginary regular voter choose Trump or this
candidate? That's the wrong way to think about
it. Instead, according to Rachel's theory,
you would say, what effect would this candidate
have on who chooses to come out and vote for
them or against them or their opponent for
their opponent and who chooses simply to stay
home? Would Bernie get more Trumpists to vote
for Donald Trump? That's the type of question
you ask. If you believe this model instead
of the swing voter model, and of course if
you believe this model, the campaign strategy
shifts away from arguing with people you don't
agree with to try to convince them to vote
for your candidate simply to finding people
that are already basically on your side and
making sure that they understand the importance
of getting out to vote and activating voters,
which is exactly what I've been saying for
year, for years, and this is very obvious
in a very superficial sense.
If you find 10 people that generally agree
with your political view who didn't vote last
time, the amount of time you would have to
spend to get a couple of them to go out and
vote is going to be far less than finding
one Trumpist and arguing with them about why
they should vote for somebody other than Trump.
In fact, presenting the Trumpist with facts
about why their view that Trump is the right
person is completely wrong. As we know from
behavioral economics is almost guaranteed
to fail and very often gets people more sort
of ingrained in their preexisting beliefs.
If you find people that already agree with
you and make it easy for them to vote, offer
to help them to vote. Give them some general
ideas about why it would be really important
that they go out there and vote. You're not
really convincing them of much other than
saying you're allowed to vote and you should
vote in.
That's it. You will make way more progress
that way and that correlates so tightly with
the theory that Rachel bike coffer is putting
forward here. Let me know what you think about
her article, which is or the story about her
rather in Politico which has spread wide,
uh, S been spread very widely over the weekend.
Let me know what you think also about how
this relates to contingencies and different
enclaves of voters
in the 2020 election. Specifically,